françois devedjian avocat et militant
pour la reconnaissance de la république
à dieu au karabagh zahour un sadique
bailie juriste spécialiste du droit
public et du droit des étrangers vous
êtes proche si je ne me trompe pas de la
présidente de l'association dialogues
france azerbaïdjan bonsoir messieurs et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france alors on viens de
l'entendre les deux camps s'accusent
mutuellement d'incidents évidemment il
est difficile de savoir ce qui se passe
réellement sur le terrain mais est ce
que vous semblez inévitable cette
violation du cessez-le-feu dans le
haut-karabagh françois devedjian quel
est votre sentiment
écoutez moi je reviens nom arménien du
duo car j'étais cette semaine encore
évidemment comme vous l'avez signalé
c'est difficile d'avoir une vraie
information sur ce qui s'est passé pour
autant je n'ai pas le sentiment que les
populations arméniennes et des forces
arméniennes soit dans un état d'esprit
de violer le cessez le feu instauré bp
mise en oeuvre par la russie donc j'ai
[Musique]
dans l'information évidemment mais je ne
crois pas que violer le cessez le feu en
tout cas était avait vocation à être
violée et je ne crois pas non plus que
cette violation si elle se confirme et
je crains que ce ne soit le quart soit à
l'origine des deux forces arméniennes et
je crois que vous demandez aussi la
saisine du procureur près de la cour
pénale internationale vous venez de
signer une pétition en ce sens il faut
des sanctions il faut le respect du
droit
et évidemment il y a eu un certain
nombre pour ne pas dire un nombre
significatif de crimes de guerre qui ont
été commis en particulier par les forces
azerbaïdjanaises
ils s'en sont d'ailleurs vanté sur
l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux que ce
soit facebook twitter et en particulier
je vous avoue que je n'en ai pas fait le
tour complet parce que c'est assez
écoeurant à regarder et c'est ses
méthodes et ses crimes de guerre doivent
être sanctionnés et là je ne parlerai
pas et je pense que vous confrère me
rejoindre à nos confrères juriste jeunes
eux mêmes parlent même pas d'azerbaidjan
ou d'arménie je parle quand des crimes
de guerre sont commis
quels qu'en soient les auteurs ils
doivent être poursuivis et là nous avons
un certain nombre de preuves de crimes
de guerre commis et donc nous souhaitons
que la justice soit rendue et nous
souhaitons qu'elle soit rendue par une
une cour internationale qui ne soient
pas sujets à caution à débat et qu'il ne
soit pas rendue par en particulier un
belligérant dont on va dire que les
règles démocratiques et de justice ne
sont pas le plus grand modèle qu'il
existe sur le monde daoust a dit que le
bail livre vous êtes sur la même ligne
que votre confrère il faut effectivement
on peut en tout cas parler de crimes de
guerre donc bon soir d'abord je voudrais
dire quelque chose très importante et je
m'adresse à messieurs des viols et en sa
personne a le lobby arménien en france
des sports a remis en france si le débat
en france ne prospère pas entre nous ça
cause de vous messieurs parce que vous
avez dérouillée tous les médias français
notre ambassadeur est obligé de faire ça
publiquement et je rends hommage à ft
france parce que même si la pdg de
france de rester français margarita
simoniens on peut aujourd'hui parler et
je suis là aujourd'hui pour ça et donc
par votre vie aujourd'hui par ce débat
je m'adresse à c'est ça qu'il faut
établir l'équilibré et l'accès de tous
les azerbaïdjanais de france qui veulent
parler s'il un débat si l'un arménien et
d'avoir en intérêts de tous les
programmes ces news grande journal tout
ce qu'il dit voulait donc sa trentaine
voire sadique buyvip cette violation du
cessez le feu pour certains observateurs
elle est la conséquence adam d'un accord
qui ne satisfait pleinement aucun des
deux camps vous partagez cet avis le
problème que là certainement la partie
arménien 20 cobras en découdre on a eu
plein des appels sur les réseaux sociaux
de préparation de revanche et c'est mon
point de vue si on reste donneront droit
international ce qu'il faut de voir ses
droits en terre certainement cd mérite à
reese est complètement le haut karabagh
vous savez moi
cette expérience cette possibilité
d'étudier en france à voir
2° endroits de connaissances en droit
public je pense que tout est réglable en
droit de décentralisation en droit des
étrangers on peut appliquer les mêmes
principes on peut appliquer la même donc
mode de vie on peut régler tous ces
problèmes
le problème comme j'expliquais des gens
dans ce débat ce qu' aucun pays dans le
monde les arbres jeunes y compris
n'accepterait pas sur son sol des
séparatistes des personnes avec les
armes les armes lourdes qui veulent vous
arracher votre territoire donc
autodétermination longtemps souvent mais
ce dirigeant va je les sens venir il va
encore parler de ta détermination des
protection des populations d'eau car
avant le problème que c'est une
revendication territoriale déguisés et
ça a été toujours on vous a déjà
expliqué que ce n'est pas possible
puisque l'état mr arménien c'est l'état
arménienne on vous a déjà expliqué que
ce sous le pont de vue du droit
internationaux vous avez tort on vous
expliquez que seul sous le pont de vie
historique
vous avez également le tour donc il faut
une fois l'accepter moi aujourd'hui vous
savez moi je suis né en arménie
je connais les l'arménie et je connais
mieux l'arménie mieux que vous messieurs
parce que je suis né là bas et ça c'est
la terre de mes ancêtres et je parle
encore un petit arménien en tout cas je
comprends le sens qu'on en parle et je
voudrais aujourd'hui s'adressant aux
arméniens qui me regarde partout dans le
monde parce que la france est diffusée
partout je veux de mon arménien et
romane arméniens les sensing écoutez moi
les arméniens parce que ça suffit les
mensonges les des tragédies arménien
elle que je comprends bien le dossier
clé derrière et de sauts siècle c'est
parce que l'arménie était menti même
aujourd'hui même si pendant cette guerre
on a menti au peuple arménien on dit que
tout va bien au front qu'on va gagner
et le résultat c'est quoi l'été c'est
les morts oui 2783 azéri sonore ou leurs
terres parce qu'on a libéré le
territoire parce qu'un entendu dans sept
ans mais les arméniens qui sont partiaux
carburant mort pourquoi pourquoi ils
sont morts tous ces gens là alors j'ai
envie on aux crimes de guerre que vous
évoquez vous dit qu'il voulait rendre
justice d'abord il a autant des vidéos
des quotas azéri soi disant que le côté
arménien certains vidéo soit disant
présumé azéri se sont révélées fausses
moi personnellement quand la guerre
c'était le personnes militaires est en
cours première j'étais choqué quand je
reçus les vidéos c'était les soldats
arméniens qui faisait des services où le
cadavre à 0
je suis un poker en général de tp
j'écris sur le twitter et je voyais en
copie donc bien sûr tous les crimes de
guerre doit être investigués tous les
crimes de guerre-- doivent être punis
mais messieurs d'abidjan bien sûr il
doit pas oublier également que si on
parle des crimes de guerre si on prend
les crimes de génocide
il faut parler de tous les crimes qui
ont été commis hier va le décorer
pendant la première d'un dirigeant fois
parlé de crime de khodjali donc si on
parle de vous est directement la cible
et des propos d ailleurs à sadi sadique
bailie visiblement c'est la statue du
c'est la question du statut du haut
karabagh qui est toujours en question
aujourd'hui malgré ce cessez-le-feu cet
accord de cessez-le-feu
je voudrais remercier je voudrais
d'abord vous remercier mon contradicteur
puisque je comprends ces propos qui le
reconnaît le génocide arménien et c'est
pour moi quelque chose d'important dont
je le remercie j'aimerais bien que un
second génocide notre produit spa et au
delà de ça je crois que il est difficile
de dialoguer avec des gens dont les
larmes la plus absolue
on va pas refaire ici ce n'est ni le
lieu et nous n'en avons pas le temps
un rappel de l'histoire mais le haut
karabagh larissa le non armés lien est
arménien depuis plusieurs millénaires
tigran actigreen le grand roi d'arménie
qui a fondé une capitale au 1er siècle
avant jésus-christ cette terre a
toujours été le berceau de de l'arménie
elle a été séparée de l'arménie
uniquement en 1920 à part le fait du
prince soviétique dont voilà mêmes
chouchi dont les azéris revendique
l'appartenance en réalité chouchi est
devenue une terre azéri à partir de 1920
1921 après qu'ils aient massacrer tous
les arméniens
l'idée c'est une pratique usuelle des
populations turques de massacres et de
s'installer de changer les noms et après
de revendiquer l'histoire des gens
qu'ils ont exterminé on a l'habitude de
ça on a l'habitude des mensonges donc
louis
je rappellerai sur le droit
international qu'il faut le distinguer
de la diplomatie et le droit
international il est en particulier
fondée sur la charte des nations unies
doit premiers mois pour mémoire pardon
l'article 1er qui définit les buts des
nations unies définit dans les buts le
droit des peuples à disposer d'eux-mêmes
et l'article 2 qui définit les moyens
s'ils ont pour objet d'atteindre ses
buts parle de l'intégrité territoriale
et donc il faut pas inverser les
principes l'intégrité territoriale n'a
que pour seul objet de défendre le droit
des peuples à disposer d'eux-mêmes
l'intégrité territoriale peut être
invoquée en protection du droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes et nous
demandons ni plus ni moins que ça alors
je sais que la diplomatie internationale
pour des raisons diverses et variées
privilégie aujourd'hui l'intégrité
territoriale parce que c'est plus facile
mais ce n'est pas le droit c'est la
diplomatie c'est les rapports de force
entre les puissants et entre les états
et les arméniens ont bien conscience que
dans ce conflit et dans ces différends
qui opposent les plus forts ce ne sont
pas nous nous n'avons jamais d'ailleurs
été les plus forts dans l'histoire et
nous en avons très souvent trop souvent
et encore aujourd'hui payer le prix
monsieur g est évidemment très délicat
vous défendez tous les deux des prêts
des dépositions
à l'opposé savoure sa digue je voudrais
qu'on vienne si vous le voulez bien sûr
l'accord de paix qui a été signé en
novembre et ce qu'il représente une base
suffisante pour pour la paix que réclame
aujourd'hui sur le terrain à la fois
arménien et azerbaïdjanais
on en voit s'il vous plaît vous savez
mon intime conviction qu'on n'aura pas
le p donc toute la vérité sera pas dit
malheureusement les contradicteurs
arménien est toujours en vente réinvente
l'histoire
bon j'ai pas le temps mais je fais des
conférences en ce moment pour mes
compatriotes jean michel david gens de
venir m'écouter aussi sous le joug et je
veux lui bien expliquer comment le
peuple azéri a été transmis dre et par
les traités successifs de toute manière
de qwikster glisten et de kuryk shaikh
comment le haut karabagh est entré en
tant que territoire azéri dans l'empiré
russe et comment toute cette population
et est dépeuplé et comment mes ancêtres
qui habitait à canal dérivant à erévan
et est dépeuplé et le nombre des
personnes qui étaient transmis les
massacrer donc je peux ou bien expliquer
ça il n'a pas de soucis donc sous le
droit international je découvre que
monsieur d'éviction s'il vous plaît pas
sans nous manque on va être obligé de
3,2 d'intégrité territoriale subordonné
au droit des peuples à disposer d'eux
mêmes non je pense que le franchement
madame le seule chose à faire c'est
démilitarisé le haut karabagh et hylas 2
2e shawcross trop chose à faire il faut
que la diaspora arménienne laisse le
peuple et du duo karabagh le peuple
l'arménie aussi les sa part laisse
tranquille parce que les arméniennes
avec l'ouverture des communications ils
pourront se développer
ils pourront être moins dépendant de
diaspora toxiques qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui et le peuple heures
d'immersion les arméniens du karabagh
qui sont nos citoyens je vous assure
qu'on trouve messi décentralisation les
préfets et tous les dispositifs de droit
public
merci à tous les deux mercier avoue sas
d'amour un sadique bailie juristes
spécialisés du droit des étrangers vous
défendiez on l'a compris la position de
l'azerbaïdjan face avoue françois
devedjian avocat militant pour la
reconnaissance de la république du haut
karabagh on aura évidemment l'occasion
d'aborder à nouveau cette thématique
éminemment
délicate merci à vous